la solitude vous connaissez sûrement le
mot mais est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà
demandé ce qu'il y avait derrière dans
le sens qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en
fait mais aussi dans le sens ça touche
qui vraiment et puis surtout qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour
[Musique]
aider il y a quelques temps déjà on
s'était demandé si la solitude était une
maladie dans une vidéo vous vous
souvenez on s'était posé plein de
questions sur la solitude qui se
souvient de Gilbert BCO il a chanté la
solitude ça n'existe pas la solitude ça
existe de ouf c'est même le mal du
siècle solitude donc ce serait le mal du
siècle apparemment il y a match quand
même he pour le mal du siècle oui bon
bref oui bref on en était arrivé à la
conclusion qu'il y a pas une solitude
mais plusieurs mais on va y revenir et
on avait fait ce constat la solitude ces
effets négatifs en tout cas ça touche
énormément de monde beaucoup plus qu'on
le pense et pour plein de raisons
différentes retournez regarder la vidéo
vous allez voir cette vidéo elle est
sortie le 11 mars 2020 quelques jours
avant le premier confinement et elle
s'appuyait sur les études de de l'époque
mais depuis le covid est passé par là et
en 2022 il y a eu une nouvelle étude sur
la solitude en France et on a appris
deux trucs importants le premier sans
surprise c'est que les choses se sont
aggravées avec la pandémie les
confinements et cetera il y a encore
plus de gens qui souffrent de solitude
chronique aujourd'hui qu'avant tout ça
le deuxième c'est que pendant la crise
il y a une forme de solidarité qui s'est
mise en place une sorte d'entraide pour
soutenir les gens qui souffraient
d'isolement ah bah c'est bien ça ah si
bah ah oui oui c'est bien ou mais une
fois que ça a été fini et ben toutes ces
bonnes habitudes elles ont disparu il y
a pas eu de monde d'après enfin si c'est
redevenu le monde d'avant mais en pire
ah ou en 2022 on estimait qu'il y avait
9,5 millions de personnes qui vivaient
dans la solitude chronique contre 6,5
million avant la crise sanitaire d'après
une autre étude qui date de janvier 2023
ce serait même 11 millions de personnes
qui seraient touché en France et en plus
il y a un autre effet collatéral positif
qui a malheureusement disparu u en même
temps que les masques dans les
transports pendant cette période de
crise il y a eu une prise de conscience
collective du problème de solitude et
d'isolement vu qu'il y a plein de gens
qui ont découvert ce que ça faisait donc
il y a eu une sorte de libération de la
parole sur ces sujets là malheureusement
une fois que la vie est redevenue comme
avant et ben d'après l'étude dont je
vous parle les questions de solitude
elles ont été de moins en moins
considérées comme quelque chose
d'important et les gens ont reconnu
qu'ils étaient moins attentifs aux
personnes qui en souffrent autour d'eux
donc vous voyez au rythme où vont les
choses le mal du siècle il est bien
parti pour être le mal du siècle
prochain aussi sauf si on fait quelque
chose et vous allez voir qu'il y a des
trucs à faire mais avant de voir ça on
va faire un petit tour du sujet en se
posant trois questions la solitude c'est
quoi si on regarde la définition du
Larousse voilà ce qu'on trouve solitude
état de quelqu'un qui est seul
momentanément ou habituellement exemple
profiter d'un instant de solitude pour
réfléchir aimer la solitude de état de
quelqu'un qui est psychologiquement seul
exemple solitude morale donc la solitude
c'est être seul bon on n'est pas très
avancé mais on note quand même deux
choses d'abord on aborde la notion
d'être psychologiquement seul et de
solitude morale ce qui implique que la
solitude c'est aussi une histoire de
ressenti et donc qu'on peut se sentir
seul même s'il y a du monde autour
ensuite la définition elle considère pas
d'emblé la solitude le fait d'être seul
comme quelque chose de négatif les
exemples du départ c'est même des
situations positive on parle même
d'aimer la solitude et c'est en ça que
je vous disais qu'il y a plusieurs
formes de solitude celle qu'on choisit
et celle qu'on subit celle qui est
temporaire et celle qui dure celle qu'on
vit et celle qu'on ressent et donc celle
qui fait du bien et celle qui fait du
mal et donc évidemment selon tous les
cas de figure elle est plus ou moins
bien vécue la solitude ça fait quoi
selon les cas la solitude elle peut être
libératrice ou destructrice au quel cas
on parle plutôt d'isolement il y a
quasiment autant de cas de figure qu'il
y a de personnes mais en gros la
solitude l'isolement social ça commence
à faire du mal quand c'est quelque chose
qu'on a pas choisi quand c'est quelque
chose qu'on subit et quand c'est quelque
chose qu'on perçoit de manière négative
et encore plus si ça dure dans le temps
depuis quelques années qu'on s'intéresse
au problème maintenant on sait que
l'isolement social à terme il finit par
avoir des conséquences sur la santé
physique on a même dit que c'était plus
mauvais pour la santé que fumer 15
cigarettes par jour mais il a surtout un
impact sur la santé mentale et comme les
deux sont liés bah ça s'auto entretient
et au-delà des conséquences sur l'humeur
sur le moral et cetera le fait d'avoir
des interactions sociales régulières le
fait de discuter de réfléchir et cetera
ça fait travailler notre mémoire et ce
qu'on appelle nos fonctions cognitives
c'est-à-dire nos capacités cérébrale
pour dire les choses autrement échanger
avec des gens c'est bon pour notre
cerveau et à l'inverse bah la solitude
ça touche qui la question ça serait
plutôt qui souffre le plus d'isolement
social ok allez on la refait qui souffre
le plus d'isolement social dans l'absolu
cell et ceux qui souffrent le plus
d'isolement social c'est cell et ceux
qui supportent le moins la solitude et
ça ça dépend notamment du rapport qu'on
a avec soi-même à quel point est-ce
qu'on supporte de se retrouver en tête
à-tête avec soi-même par exemple ça
dépend de tout un tas de facteurs de ce
genre mais quand même pragmatiquement on
sait que la solitude l'isolement c'est
moins bien vécu si c'est subi et on sait
qu'il y a des situations qui favorisent
l'isolement social ça peut être un
problème de santé mentale qui pousse au
repli sur soi ça peut être des facteurs
géographique comme le fait de vivre dans
des régions isolées avec peu d'occasions
de nouer des relations sociales ça peut
être parce on vit loin des gens qu'on
connaît après un déménagement par
exemple il y a aussi tout un tas de
situations qui font que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de temps à consacrer aux
interactions sociales si vous êtes seul
à élever une famille par exemple ou si
vous avez un boulot très prenant autre
cas de figure les personnes en situation
de handicap parce qu'elles peuvent
cumuler plusieurs facteurs dont on vient
de parler selon leur handicap la
mobilité réduite par manque d'accès au
transport par exemple mais aussi des
impératifs de temps parce que les soins
les démarche administrative et cetera ça
peut être assez lourd et si on a pas
d'aide ben ça peut être compliqué à
gérer tout seul les difficultés
financières aussi parce que les loisirs
tout ça non seulement ça coûte cher mais
en plus tout est pas forcément
accessible tout ça additionné au
facteurs géographique aux situations de
famille qui peuvent les concerner aussi
bien sûr par rapport à l'isolement
géographique par exemple trouver des
bars et des restos accessibles bah c'est
encore moins facile quand il en a pas
beaucoup près de chez soi et pareil
c'est pas évident d'aller voir ses potes
quand ils ont pas de logement accessible
sans parler des difficultés à trouver du
travail pour les personnees en situation
de handicap parce que oui le travail
c'est aussi une forme de lien social
bref c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
maintenant les personnes en situation de
handicap souffrent plus de solitude et
d'isolement social que les autres c'est
un fait voilà maintenant qu'on y voit un
petit peu plus clair il est temps de se
poser une autre question la dernière
comment on peut aider quelqu'un qui se
sent seul alors évidemment ça dépend des
raisons pour lesquelles cette personne
est seule et des raisons pour lesquelles
elle vit mal son isolement mais
clairement il y a plein de moyens
d'aider les gens à rompre leur solitude
la première c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de faire c'est prendre conscience
du problème vous avez un peu comme
pendant les les confinements pendant les
couvre-feu et cetera quand on était
toutes et tous confrontés à ça soit
directement soit indirectement à travers
des gens qu'on connaît en prendre
conscience pour libérer la parole sur le
sujet en prendre conscience aussi pour
être attentif aux autres ne serait-ce
que se poser la question est-ce que
cette personne se sent seul et du coup
bah repérer les personnes qui sont
susceptibles de se sentir seul autour de
nous ok mais concrètement on fait quoi
bah concrètement prendre des nouvelles
c'est un bon début un message un petit
coup de fil demander comment ça va mais
pas en mode formule de politesse en mode
je veux vraiment savoir comment tu vas
comment tu te sens l'étape d'après c'est
de donner un peu de votre temps prendre
des nouvelles mais pas juste une fois
régulièrement proposer de se voir de
rendre visite alors ces personnes qui se
sentent seul qui ça peut être ça peut
être votre pote qui est pas très à
l'aise socialement ça peut être votre
collègue qui est célibataire depuis
longtemps et qu' vit pas bien ça peut
être une personne âgée dans votre
famille ou dans votre voisinage
quelqu'un que vous connaissez qui peut
pas se déplacer comme il veut à cause
d'un handicap et cetera et cetera et
puis ça ça peut être quelqu'un que vous
n'avez jamais vu parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est isolé justement et
dans ces cas-là si vous savez pas quoi
faire et ben il y a des associations qui
font ça très bien je vous en avez parlé
il y a quelques temps sur les réseaux
sociaux l'association APF France
handicap ils ont une opération qui lutte
contre l'isolement des personnes en
situation de handicap ça s'appelle les
bus solidaires le concept et ben c'est
des minibus qui vont partout en France
rencontrer des personnes en situation de
handicap isolé les équipes de
l'association vont les voir dans des
petits villages à la campagne par
exemple parce qu'on a vu dans certains
endroits la ruralité c'est quelque chose
qui renforce l'isolement social et la
solitude je vous avais invité à
participer en envoyant un petit mot sur
le site d'APF France handicap des idées
de recettes de films de chansons feelg
des petits messages sympas et cetera et
cetera alors déjà un grand merci à
toutes et à tous d'avoir participé
c'était vraiment super les volontaires
de l'association sont allés dans les
villes et les villages avec les bus
solidaires donc ça permet aux personnes
en situation de handicap bah de venir
discuter avec des gens avec les
bénévoles mais aussi avec d'autres
personnes isolées comme elles ça leur
permet aussi d'avoir de l'aide pour
différentes démarches administratives et
cetera ça crée du lien social en fait et
là en plus donc on leur a remis vos
messages tout vos messages il y en a eu
plein c'était super une prochaine fois
j'irai avec eux et je vous raconterai
alors vous avez peut-être l'impression
que c'est pas grand-chose mais je vous
assure que c'est hyper important ce
genre de démarche donc hésitez pas à le
faire ou à le refaire hésitez pas à vous
engager personnellement soit en solo
soit dans une association l'engagement
ça peut prendre plusieurs formes ça peut
passer par un don par exemple ça aide
les association à mettre en place ce
genre d'opération avec un don pour les
bus solidaires les équipes d'APF France
handicap elles peuvent acheter des
nouveaux bus donc parcourir plus de
territoire donc rencontrer plus de
personnes en situation de handicap isolé
voilà donc je vous ai mis le lien vers
le site d'APF France handicap dans la
description voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Musique]
bien